welcome to this talk on concentration
bands for Quantum States and limitations
on the qaoa from polynomial
approximations I'm Tony this is Joint
work with anorag anshu
so the main thing that we want to do
here is to prove concentration balance
and for this we use a technique called
local approximations and I'll begin by
introducing this technique kind of at a
high level
and then in the paper we use this to
prove bounds for all sorts of quantum
States here I want to focus on two
classes one is the output states of
shallow Quantum circuits and the other
is the output states of something that
we call dense hamiltonian Evolution
which for now you can just think of as
like a generalization of shallow
circuits
and it turns out that one instance of
this dense hamiltonian evolution
is the evolution that's implemented by
the so-called Quantum approximate
optimization algorithm which I'll also
explain when we get there
so these concentration bands also apply
to the output states of this algorithm
and it turns out that we can use the
concentration balance and some
additional properties to prove
limitations on this algorithm as well
so first let me just say what we
actually mean by concentration balanced
so Quantum States and really what we
mean is concentration balance for a
particular classical probability
distribution associated with a Quantum
state
this probability distribution has got
the Hemingway distribution
and you get it as follows you take some
n qubit Quantum State row and you
measure this in the computational basis
so you get some n bit string and you
take the Hamming weight of that string
so you count up the number of ones in
that string
and this will get you some probability
distribution over all of the possible
Hamming weights or all of the integers
between 0 and n and this is the
hammingway distribution of the state row
and then when we say we prove
concentration balance for Quantum States
really what we mean is to we prove
concentration balance for the sending
weight distribution
now we can also generalize this to
concentration for other observables as
long as these observables change kind of
slowly enough as the Hemingway changes
but for this talk I'll only be concerned
with the Hemingway distribution itself
so this is what we mean by concentration
balance why might you want to prove one
so these originally came out of quantum
statistical mechanics where they're used
for example to prove thermalization
properties of quantum States
but more recently and maybe more
interestingly for itcs and these also
turn out to be a very useful tool in
Quantum complexity Theory so for example
the recent proof of the nlts conjecture
by Andrew breitman and nurka uses
concentration Brands as a very Central
ingredient in their proof
and related to these complexity
theoretic applications as we'll see
later we can also use concentration
bounds to prove limitations on Quantum
algorithms
so just to make this motivation a bit
more concrete let me give you kind of
like the meta argument for how to prove
limitations from concentration bounds
and we'll later see this on the
particular example of qaoa so suppose
you have some algorithm a that is meant
to solve some problem p and you should
think if P had an optimization problem
so there's some sense of kind of how
good a solution is
and what we would like to approve is
that algorithm a or more broadly any
algorithm from some class of algorithms
cannot perform very well on this problem
p
and for this we prove two things
separately first we prove that the
output distribution of a must be
concentrated using our concentration
bands
and then separately from that one can
for certain problems at least prove that
any good solution to problem P produced
by algorithm a can in fact not be
concentrated due to some additional
property of the problem for example
symmetry
and then we can of course conclude that
you know algorithm a can't perform very
well on problem T so that's the kind of
high level idea of how to use
concentration bounds to prove
limitations
okay so now let's actually dive into
this slightly more technical aspect of
this which is how to prove these
concentration paths
and as I said this goes via something
called local approximation so we need
two definitions here one is for what are
called local operators so K local
operator on some n keyword spaces in
operator are that we can decompose into
a sum of terms RI and each term in the
sum here is allowed to act non-trivially
on at most K qubits meaning that its
identity everywhere except on almost K
qubits and then these K qubits it can be
anything at once
so I'll call this the local
decomposition and of course it's not
unique and also just point out that
whenever I say local here I never mean
geometrically local right so these
qubits that can be involved in this term
here they can be any care keywords
there's no need to arrange them on some
letters and restrict the nearest
neighbor interactions so this is kind of
the most General sense of locality
then a k Epsilon local or an
approximately local operator is exactly
what you would expect it's just an
operator that is Epsilon close to a k
local operator so the sum of our I here
may be a local operator then Q would be
K Epsilon local if the infinity Norm
between these two is at most Epsilon and
I'll call this the local approximation
to q and of course that's also not
unique
so just some quick examples they give
you some kind of concrete intuition here
so for example we can take the single
keyword projector onto qubit I and then
take the expectation of all of the
qubits so this means it projects onto
the zero State on the ith qubit and it
is identity everywhere else then this is
a one local operator right because it's
already written in this form of a sum
where each of these terms acts not
trivially only on the if qubit
on the other hand if we for example look
at the project onto the all zero State
on N qubits this would be n local right
because it acts non-trivially on all of
the N qubits at the same time and
there's no way to decompose it into a
sum of local terms
and then we could for example try to
construct a local approximation to This
n local Operator by taking this one
local operator of single qubit zero
projectors and taking it as some power k
and this would give you a k local
operator because you sort of multiply
out the terms and you get at most K of
these single keyword projectors
multiplied together on different qubits
so it's K local and this would be an
approximation to the or zero projector
we can compute the approximation error
here but it's not really important
because it's just meant as a simple
example of intuition
okay so how are these local operators
related to concentration bonds and this
is via this Lemma here which is already
kind of implicit in this earlier work by
korahara atal
so what does this say it says that if we
have some pure Quantum State PSI and its
projector is a k Epsilon local operator
in the sense of the previous slide
then if we look at the Hemingway
distribution of this state this
distribution has the following sort of
concentration like property the
probability that it is bigger than its
median plus the locality K of the
approximation here decays with the
approximation error Epsilon
so this doesn't quite look like a
concentration bound yet because in a
concentration bound really we want to
like pick a deviation K right and then
we want to be told what the probability
of the random variable deviating by that
much is bounded by
here this works for one particular
choice of K and Epsilon
so you should imagine that whenever we
apply this Lemma we have a kind of
family of local approximations to the
state one for each value of K
and this gets us a family of these
inequalities one for each deviation K
here and collectively these behave like
a concentration band and they also have
the usual property that if you look at
bigger deviations corresponding to
bigger localities in your approximation
then this Epsilon here will Decay right
because as you allow a bigger locality
in your approximation you can
approximate your state more and more
closely so the Epsilon will decay
I should also mention that of course the
symmetric thing also holds right so if
you put it less than here and median
minus K here then the same thing holds
so it is symmetric like like most
concentration bounds are
so the consequence of this is that to
prove that a state has concentration
properties really it suffices to find
local approximations to that state right
and then we'll just run it through this
Lemma and get concentration balance
okay so that's kind of the high level
framework for proving concentration
balance now let's actually prove some
concrete bounds and the first that I
want to mention here are for the output
states of shallow Quantum circuits
so here we prove the following let PSI
be the output state of a depth D circuit
on n qubits
then for any choice of Q which is kind
of like the deviation this K on the
previous slide after some rescaling the
projector onto this output State PSI is
Q times 2 to the D Epsilon local
for an approximation error Epsilon which
decays like e to the minus Q squared
over n
so there are a lot of parameters here
but this becomes slightly easier to look
at if we actually run it through the
Lemma from the previous slide
and to get the concentration bound and
what the concentration bound will say is
you know let Psy be the output status
for depth of the circuit and Cuba says
above then the probability that this
Hemingway distribution deviates by K
from its median where K is now any
deviation that you can choose this
decays like e to the minus K squared
over n and then you have this additional
sort of damping Factor here which
depends on the depth of the circuit
okay so the K here corresponds to the Q
times 2 to the D here
and really like the main qualitative
feature of this found is that if you
look at constant depth so D is just a
constant then this the stamping Factor
down here becomes a constant as well so
we get the usual gaussian or churn-off
like concentration for constant depth
Quantum circuits so in this sense you
can kind of think of this as a Quantum
generalization of the churn-off bound
because if you pick the depth you know
one Circle or even depth zero circuit
then you could actually prove this using
the turnoff down and it would get the
same result up to some constants and
this sort of extends this to any
constant depth circuit with the same
kind of gaussian decay
so let me say very briefly at least what
the proof idea here is so because this
is a bounded depth a depth B circuit we
can use a like an argument to write the
output State this projector onto the
output State rather as the classical and
function applied to a set of commuting
two to the D local projectors so this 2
to the D here comes from the lycon
argument
and once we've done this we can now
replace the and function by the optimal
degree Q polynomial approximation to the
end function so the second step is
purely classical there's a sort of known
and it has been known for a long time
optimal polynomial approximation to the
and function and if you plug this
polynomial approximation into the first
step replacing the end function by that
then you get a polit degree Q polynomial
applied to 2 to the D local projectors
which gets you a q times 2 to the the
local object and this is how you get
this Q times 2 to the D here and then
this approximation error Epsilon here
just follows from the approximation
error of the polynomial approximation of
the classical and function
okay so that's all I want to say on
shallow Quantum circuits now let's move
on to dense simultaneous Evolution and I
want to introduce Dan's hamiltonian
Evolution as a kind of natural
generalization of shallow circuits and
for this let's first write shallow
circuits as hamiltonian Evolution so if
you have a depth D circuit this means
you can write it as a product of sort of
single layer unitaries three of them
and each of these single layer unitaries
here you can write as e to the I times
some hamiltonian
and because in each layer of the circuit
you can only have two qubit gates acting
on this joint sets of qubits each of
these individual layer hamiltonians if
you like is a two local hamiltonian
where all local terms act on disjoint
sets of qubits
so we can represent this by an
interaction graph which looks like this
where now the qubits on the vertices
here and I draw an edge between them if
there is a term in say this H1
hamiltonian so this is for one of the
hamiltonians if there is a term here
that acts on both of these qubits at the
same time
okay so because of this requirement that
each layer in the circuit is a tensor
product of gates acting on disjoint
qubits you get this very kind of
disconnected interaction graph for each
of these layer hamiltonians
now a dense hamiltonian evolution is
just the same thing except that we drop
this requirement that the interaction
graph here has to be this weird
disconnected thing and we instead allow
any interaction graph
so it's again you know product of
hamiltonian evolutions and now each of
these these hamiltonians HJ here can be
any L local instead of just two local
commuting hamiltonian on N qubits so all
of these hamiltonians are of course also
commuting we still preserve the
requirement that the hamiltonian needs
to be commuting but we now allow
interaction graphs which allow
interactions between any qubits of the
system
also just to be clear when I say
commuting hamiltonian here I mean that
you know each of these hamiltonians here
is commuting in the sense that it can be
written as a sum of commuting local
terms but of course the hamiltonians in
the different layers here they don't
need to commute among themselves right
so one example as we'll see in a minute
of such a dense hamiltonian evolution is
this qaoa algorithm that I mentioned
earlier applied on dense constrained
optimization problems
okay and now the goal here is to prove
again that the output state of these
hamiltonian Evolutions so this unit area
here apply to the or zero State can be
approximated by local operators and once
we have this you know we get
concentration balance as before
so I want to make the kind of high level
point that it's sort of surprising that
this is even true
because in the shallow Quantum circuit
setting there's a very natural intuition
for why you would expect to get
concentration which is that in each
layer here you know you have a very
tight control over which qubits get
correlated with which keywords right in
this one layer say this keyword can get
correlated with this qubit but this
qubit can't get correlated with any of
the other qubits so you can really kind
of manually track correlations and this
is precisely what we did in the Litecoin
argument this gets you some kind of weak
form of Independence and and this
intuitively is what gets you the
concentration
but the stencilian evolution really
breaks that intuition because a single
layer of hamiltonian evolution here can
correlate any two qubits with any other
two qubits
or more generally in the local case it
can correlate any groups of L qubits um
together
so I think really the update that we
should make based on this to our
intuition is that concentration balance
arise more from these local
approximations than from some kind of
Independence property as you might think
in the churn-off case or the shallow
Quantum circuits case
okay now what is the actual
concentration bound that we prove for
the stand simultaneous Evolutions
um we prove that if we have such a
sequence of our local commuting
hamiltonians that satisfy some
additional technical condition uh we
call it a subset Norm condition it kind
of says that the weights inside the
hamiltonian are sort of well spread
among the the interaction terms
then if we run p a little o of log log
and slightly super constant number of
layers of the simultaneous evolution
then the output state of this evolution
is K Epsilon local for K being little o
of N and Epsilon decaying sub
exponentially and then
so we also have more explicit
non-asympatic bands so you can figure
particular p and a particular K and you
get the corresponding bound on Epsilon
but I picked this asymptotic version
because K being little o of n is kind of
the largest possible K the largest
possible locality that you can allow
that's still interesting because if the
locality K is sublinear and N this means
as n goes to Infinity the kind of
proportion that each local term takes up
among the N qubits vanishes right so
it's it's still like very local but it's
the the least local thing that's still
interesting
okay so this talks about local
approximations we can then again run it
through the Lemma from from earlier and
we get the probability that the Heming
weight of such an an output State here
of then simultaneous evolution deviates
by some sublinear amount from its median
decay sub-exponentially
okay so the final thing I want to talk
about is how to use these concentration
bounds to prove limitations on this QA
or a algorithm that I've referenced a
bunch of times by now and for this let
me first tell you what this algorithm
actually does it's a Quantum algorithm
that's meant to approximate the solution
to classical constraint optimization
problems so these are problems where you
have some objective function that you
maximize over these n sort of bit values
or plus or minus one values
and a local here means that you can
write this objective function as a sum
of terms with like some super some
coefficient here J and the product of L
of these values set High
now if we have such a constraint
optimization problem we can naturally
associate a commuting hamiltonian with
this which is just a hamiltonian that
you get by replacing these these bits Z
here by the corresponding poly matrices
and then the maximum eigenvalue of this
hamiltonian is exactly the same as the
the maximization here
foreign
does is It prepares a particular Quantum
state which is this how do you get this
Quantum state so you start from the sort
of equal superposition of everything
which is this plus State tensor n
and then you evolve by some sort of time
if you like Gamma 1 with this cop
hamiltonian hn
and then you do an evolution
independently on all of the qubits with
the Pali X Matrix will sometimes better
one and so on you just keep repeating
this for some number of PDF layers
so I'm not going to give much intuition
for why this should work but the hope is
that you can find good values of beta
and gamma such that if you measure this
output State here in the computational
basis you get a good solution to this
constrained optimization problem after
converting say from bits to these plus
minus one values
and in fact if the number of layers here
p goes to Infinity you can prove that
you can find choices of beta and gamma
such that you get the optimal solution
to the cop
so really the question here is what
happens for like small P right because
this is meant to be some kind of
near-term algorithm where we Implement
some really like limited number of
layers of these evolutions
so there are two problems here one is
how to find good choices of beta and
gamma and the other is once you've found
these choices how good is your solution
um we ignore the first problem we just
assume that you've like magically found
optimal betas and Gammas even though
this may be hard in general
and we prove that even then there are
strong limitations on the performance of
this qioa at level P which is little of
log log n so it's like slightly super
constant
but importantly this works also for
constrained optimization problems that
have dense constraint graphs so that
have very many terms here and any any
set of L bits here can be involved in in
any terms
let me briefly mention some previous
results here so the setting that's
mostly been analyzed so far is the case
of sparse constrained rust because then
you can again do some kind of
correlation tracking similar to the
shallow circuits thing that I described
earlier and in that case there are many
limitations known from from these papers
in the case of dense cops there's this
very recent paper which is really nice
and that we took a lot of inspiration
from as well which proves that in the
asymptotic limit of infinitely many bits
the expectation value of you know
measuring the state and then plugging
the solution into their that constrained
optimization problem there are
limitations on how well this expectation
value can perform for a constant number
of layers
so our results improve upon this in two
ways firstly instead of having a
constant number of layers we have the
slightly super constant number of layers
and then secondly instead of looking at
the expectation value we actually prove
that the probability of getting a good
solution is is really quite small
okay how do we prove this we prove this
using a structural property of cops
called the overlap Gap property
and formerly a cop has this overlap Gap
property of any kind of good Solutions
are either close or far
and in particular if the parameters are
sufficiently stronger then you get
clustering of good Solutions so all of
these blue dots here are kind of the
good solutions that are close enough to
Optimal
and the ogp says that with sufficiently
strong parameters at least all of these
good Solutions are grouped in these
clusters which are linearly far away
from each other in the Heming Cube
and this paper here shows that in fact
for random spin models which is the case
that we're mostly interested in this ogp
holds even though I should point out
that they don't get this sufficiently
strong parameters here and to get this
clustering but it seems to be implicit
in that proof that that this holds as
well but technically it still needs to
be verified
okay so let's say we have a cop that has
this sufficiently strong ogp that we get
the clustering how can we use this to
prove limitations on qaoa
well we need one additional property
which is symmetry so we only look at
cops here which are symmetric under
flipping all signs so for example if you
have an L local cop this would be the
case if L is even
so let's say this has the strong ogp so
that we get clustering and we run qaoa
with level P being little of log log n
and now we want to do the argument that
I had on the very first slide of you
know you prove concentration you prove
that good Solutions can't be
concentrated and you get a contradiction
how do we do this here we prove that
because qaoa is an instance of the
sten's hamiltonian evolution and also
these extra technical conditions turn
out to be satisfied
the qaoa output state is K Epsilon local
for K being a little over n and the
sub-eximonial Epsilon that I just copied
from the concentration bounce that we
got in general
and now suppose for contradiction that
the qaoa measurement distribution
produces a good string where good is in
the sense of this overlap Gap property
with probability at least root Epsilon
so this is really like not a very strong
Pope right we only hope that we get a
good solution with this sub-exponential
probability here but nonetheless this
turns out to not even hold
so if you make this assumption that what
you can show is that by the
concentration properties of
approximately local States almost all of
that root Epsilon probability weight
must be concentrated on a single cluster
intuitively this is because all of the
other clusters are kind of too far away
and they're too far in the tail of the
distribution and for that to be hardly
any weight on them
okay so this is the concentration part
of the argument and now we need the
other part that says that good Solutions
can't be concentrated and for this we
use the symmetry so
because the cop is symmetric under
flipping signs it's fairly easy to show
that the qioa output state must be
invariant under flipping all of the bits
so applying Pali X to all of the qubits
individually this is already observed in
this earlier paper by Bravia l
and this means that each cluster in the
output distribution of the qaoa state
must have a kind of partner cluster
right cluster in the ogp sense where all
the bits are simply flipped but the
weight of these partner clusters must be
equal by symmetry of the QA state
but this is a contradiction to three
because in three we prove that all of
the weight must be concentrated on just
a single cluster so there can't be a
sort of far away partner cluster with
equal weight as well
so the conclusion is that for such cops
qaa with level P being little o of log
log n cannot produce good Solutions with
probability higher than the sub
exponential here
okay let me wrap up and we prove
concentration balance for the outputs of
shallow Quantum circuits also objective
matrix product states which I didn't
talk about at all and the outputs of
then simultaneous Evolution and the main
proof technique is always to approximate
these states by low degree polynomials
of local operators which gets you these
local approximations
and by combining this concentration
balance with this overlap Gap property
we get strong limitations on the qaoa
for symmetric dense constraint
optimization problems at this slightly
super constant level as well
so there are many open questions here
but let me just mention the two that I
find most interesting
um firstly for dense simultaneous
Evolution we don't get the same kind of
sure enough style Decay that we get for
shallow Quantum circuits when we get
sub-exponential decay
so it's very natural to ask what the
best Decay is that you could hope for in
the case of dense simultaneous Evolution
and in particular whether you can get
gaussian concentration for that case as
well
and secondly on the qaoa side currently
the proof really relies on the Symmetry
requirement here so if we have
non-symmetric qaoa do we still get some
kind of limitations using these
concentration techniques
okay so I'll stop here and thank you for
your attention